♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
Government regulators
on Friday
seized control
of Silicon Valley Bank,
the country's 16th largest bank,
after it quickly became
the 178th largest bank.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
government regulators on Friday
seized control
of Silicon Valley Bank,
making it the largest
U.S. bank failure since 2008.
And come to think of it,
it was always a bad sign
that their ATM had a tip screen.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke
this morning
about Friday's collapse
of Silicon Valley Bank
and reassured Americans
the country's financial system
is safe.
But, remember, this is a guy
whose whole financial system
is definitely a coffee can
on a high shelf.
[ Laughter ]
"See, the thing is, they never
look up there."
That's right. President Biden
reassured Americans
the country's
financial system is safe.
Okay, I think the fact
that you're talking
about a bank collapse
proves it isn't.
That's like going to a funeral
and giving a eulogy about
how Nana's gonna be fine.
[ Laughter ]
The Oscars were held
last night,
and the film "Everything
Everywhere All at Once"
won seven awards,
including Best Picture.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Best Picture, Best Actress,
and worst butchering
in a text from your mom.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. "Everything
Everywhere All at Once"
won best picture at last
night's Academy Awards.
As for who lost -- whoever sat
behind this lady.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, my goodness.
My first Oscars.
My first Oscars."
[ Laughter ]
When asked last week
about allegations
that he participated
in a credit-card skimming scam,
New York Congressman
George Santos said
he was innocent and added,
"I'm no mastermind of anything,"
which is maybe the first
believable thing he's ever said.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Elon Musk is reportedly
planning to build a town
outside Austin, Texas, for his
Tesla and SpaceX employees
that he has described
in meetings as a utopia.
I don't know.
Have you ever been to a party
where one guy has a Tesla?
Now imagine every guy
has a Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
A tattoo artist in India
recently set
a Guinness world record
after spending
over 90 consecutive hours
giving tattoos to 64 people
and hepatitis to 63 people.
[ Laughter ]
Today was National K9
Veterans Day.
It's like regular Veterans Day,
except no fireworks.
[ Laughter ]
We have a writer, Mike Scollins,
who's obsessed with the idea
that dogs don't like fireworks.
A lot of his jokes are dependent
upon people knowing that.
And caring.
And finally, according to
a new study,
reusable water bottles
can have 14 times more bacteria
than a pet's water bowl,
but only because your cat drinks
out of it
every time you turn your back.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden signed
an executive order today
that increases background checks
on gun purchases.
From now on, gun dealers
are gonna ask your first
and last name.
[ Laughter ]
Republican presidential hopeful
Nikki Haley
said on Sunday that taxpayers
"should absolutely not bail out
Silicon Valley Bank."
But I think that's
largely because
it's polling ahead of her.
[ Laughter ]
The Pentagon said today
that a Russian jet
crashed into a U.S. military
drone over the Black Sea.
And I think I speak for
all Americans when I say,
probably an accident, right?
This doesn't have to be
a whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
Just go with accident.
Russia is reportedly
restoring hundreds
of decades-old Soviet tanks
to use against Ukraine
amid a shortage of weapons
and equipment.
Oh, they are struggling.
Next it's just gonna be,
"Any way to trick out
these T-shirt cannons?"
[ Laughter ]
Fox News host Brian Kilmeade
interviewed Florida governor
Ron DeSantis over the weekend
and played catch
while wearing suits.
It kind of ruined the flow
of the interview, though.
"So, Governor, what do you think
the U.S. role should be
in the war in --
Oh, wait, car!"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Fox News aired
an interview over the weekend
where host Brian Kilmeade
played catch
with Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
at a high school baseball field
in Iowa.
And no surprise here,
their fathers chose
not to come out of the corn
and reconnect with them.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats are reportedly worried
that efforts to ban TikTok
could make it harder
to reach young voters.
Well, you could do
what Republicans do
and reach them on Venmo.
[ Laughter ]
Just a thing that happened.
I don't know why everybody's
so weird about it.
Former president Trump
has reportedly been invited
to testify before
a New York grand jury
as part of the Manhattan
district attorney's
investigation
into hush-money payments
that were made to
adult film star Stormy Daniels.
And despite everything,
Trump was still excited
to get invited to something
in New York again.
[ As Trump ] I'm back, baby.
Any -- Any word
from the Met Ball?
Have they reached out?
[ Normal voice ] California
Congressman Mark Takano
recently reintroduced a bill
that would make a 32-hour
workweek a national standard,
which would finally
give Americans
the free time they need
to look for a third job.
[ Laughter ]
Microsoft is set on Thursday
to hold a "Future of Work with
AI" event, and this is scary --
None of the executives
can remember organizing it.
[ Laughter ]
"Playboy" is reportedly planning
to relaunch
as a digital-first magazine,
and, dude, I just found
my dad's stash in his closet.
[ Laughter ]
"The New York Times"
published an op-ed today titled
"Working from Home Is
Less Healthy than You Think."
Oh, how unhealthy could it be?
I mean -- Oh!
Oh, crap.
Is that a ghost?
[ Laughter ]
The NYPD is looking
for a group of teens
who allegedly stole more than
$40,000 worth of calculators
from high schools in the Bronx.
Said the teens,
"Actually, it's...
$41,672."
[ Laughter ]
That's how you do it, right?
In my -- In my --
In my mind's eye,
it also had that little
paper thing that was...
Hmm.
And fin-- Alright.
We're gonna go --
[ Laughter ]
Oh, boy.
How hopeful are you guys
based on this photo?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a clam was recently
discovered in Florida
that's believed to be
more than 200 years old.
And like most 200-year-old clams
in Florida,
it moved there from
the Upper West Side.
You guys, we just --
That was the monologue.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's officially a monologue.
President Biden spoke today
in Las Vegas about healthcare.
Oh, you mean that place where
everyone smokes indoors,
and it's cool to have
7:00 a.m. cocktails
as long as you haven't been
to sleep yet?
Yeah.
Sure healthcare in Vegas
is a major priority.
After Russian fighter jets
forced down
an unmanned Air Force
surveillance drone yesterday
over the Black Sea,
the White House said Russia's
actions were, "Unsafe,
unprofessional, and reckless."
Well, yeah, I mean, it's Russia.
Of course they're reckless.
They think the "Jackass" movies
are meditation videos.
After the U.S. drone
was forced down yesterday
by a Russian fighter jet,
Russia's ambassador to the U.S.
denied that
the two aircraft collided.
And Putin is claiming the drone
just fell out a window.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
former President Trump
said that his upcoming book,
"Letters to Trump,"
will show readers that he has
had a "very fascinating life."
While the fact that we have to
call that guy former president
shows that all of us have lived
a very fascinating life.
A student at
Princeton University
was arrested this week for his
alleged participation
in the Capitol attack, which
means even the Capitol Building
is easier to get into
than Harvard.
[ Laughter ]
At a rally this week in Iowa,
former President Trump said that
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
reminds him
of Utah Senator Mitt Romney,
also Francis
from "Pee-wee's Big Adventure."
[ Laughter ]
[ Whispering ] Francis!
A group of Senate Democrats
called on several retail chains,
including Costco, to sell
the abortion pill.
Though, I'm not sure that's
gonna work, because most people
would rather raise a child than
go to Costco on a Saturday.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
people who live in rural areas
are more depressed, anxious,
and neurotic
than people who live in cities.
Sounds counterintuitive, but
then again, I've never seen
truck nuts on a yellow cab.
[ Laughter ]
Want to.
Taco Bell has announced
that next month,
it will remove the Quesarito
from its menu in order to
bring back two popular items --
napkins and the bathroom code.
[ Laughter ]
And -- There was an "aw"
on the Quesarito comment.
Did you hear?
What a terrible -- You go to
a show, try to have a laugh,
and then you get terrible news
about the Quesarito.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, St. Patrick's Day
is two days away.
Well, you know what they say?
It's two days from now
somewhere!
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
has reportedly warned
that it will ban TikTok
if its Chinese parent company
doesn't sell the app.
Don't mess with this man.
He has no use
for your addictive apps.
Biden's the kind of guy
who can make it through
a whole two-week vacation
with nothing but a deck of cards
and a print edition
of "Sports Illustrated."
"You know what we're gonna do
during dinner tonight?
We're actually gonna talk
to each other! That's what!"
Treasury Secretary Janet Yellen
testified today
before the
Senate Finance Committee
and said the country's banking
system remains sound.
Specifically this sound.
[ Tires screech ]
[ Crash, glass shatters ]
[ Laughter ]
The new CEO
of Silicon Valley Bank
held a meeting yesterday
with venture capital
and start-up clients and said,
"There is no safer place
in the U.S. banking system
to put your deposits."
Plus, if you go now,
the lines are super-short!
[ Laughter ]
The Pentagon today
released footage
of a Russian jet forcing down
a U.S. surveillance drone.
Apparently what happened was
they both tried to take off
from LaGuardia at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
U.N. officials
recently discovered
during a routine inspection
that around 2.5 tons of uranium
have gone missing in Libya,
which explains why
Libya's beaches have experienced
a 600% increase in Godzillas.
[ Laughter ]
A zoo in Michigan
recently announced the birth
of a critically endangered
bongo calf,
which apparently is an animal
and not a medical condition
suffered by Matthew McConaughey.
[ Laughter ]
[ As McConaughey ]
"I got it real bad.
I got it real bad."
[ Normal voice ] The American
Kennel Club announced yesterday
that the French Bulldog
has surpassed
the Labrador Retriever
as the most popular dog breed.
So you know what that means
for you Lab owners.
-He was my dog. I'll do it.
[ Laughter ]
-So, our writer, Mike Scollins,
submitted that joke.
And, look,
we didn't have to do it.
[ Laughter ]
You know,
I'm the host of the show.
I could have just said
we're not doing it,
but I wanted to do it
because I'm trying to teach him
a lesson and --
[ Laughter ]
There's no -- The undergirding
logic of that makes no sense.
That -- That implies
that everybody
who's had a less-popular dog
until today
had to put their dogs down.
It doesn't -- Just 'cause the --
[ Sighs ]
The important thing is,
you know,
it's the start of the show,
you want to kick it off,
you want to get a good vibe
in the room,
and we showed a clip
from "Old Yeller," so...
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
longtime Green Bay Packers
quarterback Aaron Rodgers
said yesterday that it is
his intention to play next
season for the New York Jets.
It's a perfect fit
because every week the Jets
go out there intending
to play football.
And that -- That's what's
waitin' for you here, buddy.
That was a monologue.
♪♪